how do you think about those two uh or
maybe the line between the nation state
and the network state blurring in the
physical world where the network state
still needs physical space so diplomatic
relations between network states and
nation states
is actually you know what's similar to
it's similar to the crypto fiat
interface
ah okay
because it's like the interface between
cryptocurrency bitcoin and fiat currency
the us dollar
um was not something that actually uh to
my knowledge at least satoshi wrote
about originally he sort of thought that
the crypto economy
could bootstrap itself kind of
completely on its own he had like the
poker thing that was built into the app
at the beginning right but it turned out
that the btc usd
interface that exchange rate once that
exchange rate
occurred right um and you could argue it
occurred implicitly with the the pizza
day transaction right but
the exchange rate between btc and usd
that is you know like future historians
will see that as something that almost
looks like it went zero to one right
like that it looks infinite or like it
like it just goes vertical because it's
over it's very fast over a short period
of time but while we're living through
it as you know it has ups and downs and
it retraces and so on and so forth um
before you know like maybe you'll go to
infinity i i don't we'll see okay but
the thing is that um ah so this this
image by the way here this shows a
visual of what i'm talking about where
if you scroll down right
that's that's apple's ar kit which is a
preview of what you'll see with your ar
glasses so if you hold a certain nft you
see a glowing sigil you're part of this
secret society this freemasons or or
what have you and all the people who
have that nft can see that sigil and
nobody who doesn't can't right and uh
that means that you you have a layer
over the world where citizenship becomes
like single sign-on you know you have a
private key you have an nft that is your
digital passport and you can literally
see aspects of the world that others
can't it's like your physical login
right and uh so you can start to see how
with something like that you can take
all these territories around the world
and you know brand is uh it's kind of an
unfortunate term because it seems very
corporate but think about if you walk
into the google offices anywhere in the
world they're basically very similar you
know they're meant to be similar it's
got the google logo maybe there's like a
little ethnic touch for that country
like the google doodle but they're
fundamentally very similar
and that's intentional it's like a
little piece of google a slice of google
around the world but that's within the
context of commercial real estate these
are all fundamentally commercial
buildings office space what if you
extended that to residential real estate
and industrial and you had all those
linked together and it wasn't a company
but a community that owned them right
that you could do and then the branding
would be more like you have a bunch of
chinatowns for example or little india's
around the world but they're networked
together
and now you actually start having
something which nothing i'm describing
is like technically infeasible you know
all these little subroutines exist right
chinatowns exist little indies exist
google exists single silent exist all
those pieces exist right what i'm kind
of talking about is the system
integration of bringing them together
into this uh you know community that is
physically distributed but digitally
connected in one place and one way of
thinking about this by the way is if you
live in hawaii
many people who i mean they think of
themselves as part of the same country
as somebody who lives in new york
okay they're not driving to new york um
in fact they probably don't go off the
island of hawaii that frequently
so that gift that i just showed is
actually not that different from how
people live already
you know
like the you don't need that much
contiguous space in the middle it's not
flyover country it is
probably there's probably some clever
one-liner you could have but it's like
teleport over a country
you know because you're just sending the
packets over you know um
and so these other regions are as
you know so long as your individual
pockets are large enough
um and that depends you know a person in
just like one place on their own could
kind of think of themselves as like a
just like an american expat living
overseas thinks themselves as american
even if they're surrounded by a lot of
foreign nationals right like a building
that had just one person from a network
state that person would larp themselves
into thinking of themselves as part of
this larger community and once it gets
to
on the order of a hundred thousand to a
million people if and when it gets there
it's actually not that unreasonable
alert and the reason for that is that
most countries are small countries
actually here's another
graphic from the beginning of the book
that i'll show you
i mean in some way what you're
describing there are um crumbs of it
already occurring uh google is a good
example right in terms of like you think
of yourself as uh i adhere to this uh
community which happens to be a
for-profit company there's physical
space there's a single sign-on to get
into the the internal
systems but you also can kind of
extrapolate that out and you see
people doing this in a variety of
different ways
it's just no one's done it from an
actual nation-state you know
transitioning to a network state if you
will
right and so if you take a look for
example at this uh just here's a way to
calibrate like the the reasonableness of
this
if you go and look at this um link that
i just pasted in and scroll all the way
down to the bottom
most countries are small countries
okay only 14 countries are 100 million
person countries
and the reason that that is
counterintuitive is probably most people
live in big countries but most countries
are small countries right
and so the thing about that is most the
countries that the united nations
are like
you know like sub 1 sub 10 million right
and as you know we can build social
networks of that scale you know i mean
it's not trivial to build
uh uh you know a 10 million person
social network but it's definitely
doable and there's there's there's
definitely a lot of people who have
built um you know 100k one million
person followings online like you and i
are i think are at that level that's not
that's not like that exceptional right
and so now of course there's a huge
difference between
like clicking a button and following
somebody versus um actually going and
having a much higher level of commitment
to think of yourself as part of a
country
but
in terms of the horizontal scale we're
there right like we've got massive
horizontal scale for like joining
facebook and now you know the next level
up from that from spending hours and
hours a day on something which is
actually a pretty big commitment by the
way i should say um the next step up
from spending hours a day on a social
network is starting to invest huge
chunks of your net worth like
even one percent of your net worth are
considered a huge chunk into a
cryptocurrency and so we have billions
of people spending hours on social media
we have hundreds of millions of people
putting big chunks of their net worth
into cryptocurrency and so the next
question is will we have some
significant fraction of people putting
their lives into a crypto country